el tratado de la onu para la producción
de armas nucleares entra en vigor o no
esto hace que los armamentos nucleares
no se puedan utilizar y es un tributo a
los sobrevivientes de las peores bombas
de la historia el problema es que las
grandes potencias que desarrollan ese
arsenal están por fuera del pacto eeuu
china irán rusia reino unido y francia
son algunos de los países que no
ratificaron el acuerdo y por ende no
están obligados a respetarlo
china por ejemplo dice que tiene sus
propias medidas para contribuir al
desarme aunque defiende que esto debe
hacerse paso a paso con el fin de
garantizar la estabilidad mundial
station extensión sino también cree que
el proceso de desarme nuclear no puede
separarse de la realidad de la seguridad
internacional
ewan tiempo tiene su edad
hacia el mismo tiempo de la entrada en
vigor del nuevo pacto nuclear el
presidente de eeuu le está proponiendo a
rusia una extensión del new start el
único tratado en el que ambos países se
comprometen a regular las ojivas
nucleares y los misiles que producen si
no logran una prórroga el pacto
terminará el próximo 5 de febrero en que
podemos confirmar que eeuu tiene la
intención de buscar una extensión de 5
años de new start según lo permita el
tratado y esta extensión tiene todavía
más sentido cuando la relación con rusia
es antagónica como lo es en este momento
en el kremlin respondió la propuesta de
washington diciendo que está de acuerdo
con la idea de joe biden pero que
primero quiere ver propuestas concretas